google has android business how do you
overcome not having the hardware not
having Android you know our strategy is
just to build things that people really
want to use all right and you know
Facebook is the most used app whatsapp
and messenger and Instagram are some of
the next most used apps that are out
there so at some level I think that as
long as we're building services that
people really want to use and that help
people's lives then it's not as big of a
deal right and it's you know it's
something that it's certainly a little
bit stressful we feel like we can maybe
help people out more or deliver our
services a little bit better if we had
more partnerships with the with the
operating systems that we were using to
build our stuff but it's not something
that I'm not stressed about at this
point because there's just as long as we
stay focused on building our own stuff I
think that's the right thing for us to
stay focused on not worrying about what
other people are going to do